Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This name is not getting any easier, is it?
It used to be Károly Zsolnai, which was hard
enough, and now this... haha. Anyway, let's
get started.
This technique simulates how different objects
in a video sound when struck. We have showcased
some marvelous previous techniques that were
mostly limited to wooden and plastic materials.
Needless to say, there are links to these
episodes in the video description box.
A convolutional neural network takes care
of understanding what is seen in the video.
This technique is known to be particularly
suited to processing image and video content.
And it works by looking at the silent video
directly and trying to understand what is
going on, just like a human would.
We train these networks with input and output
pairs - the input is a video of us beating
the hell out of some object with a drumstick.
The joys of research! And the output is the
sound this object emits.
However, the output sound is something that
changes in time. It is a sequence, therefore
it cannot be handled by a simple classical
neural network. It is learned by a recurrent
neural network that can take care of learning
such sequences.
If you haven't heard these terms before, no
worries, we have previous episodes on all
of them in the video description box, make
sure to check them out!
This piece of work is a nice showcase of combining
two quite powerful techniques: the convolutional
neural network tries to understand what happens
in the input video, and the recurrent neural
network seals the deal by learning and guessing
the correct sound that the objects shown in
the video would emit when struck.
The synthesized outputs were compared to the
real world results both mathematically and
by asking humans to try to tell from the two
samples which one the real deal is. These
people were fooled by the algorithm around
40% of the time, which I find to be a really
amazing result, considering two things: first,
the baseline is not 50%, but 0% because people
don't pick choices at random - we cannot reasonably
expect a synthesized sound to fool humans
at any time. Like nice little neural networks,
we've been trained to recognize these sounds
all our lives, after all. And second, this
is one of the first papers from a machine
learning angle on sound synthesis. Before
reading the paper, I expected at most 10 or
20 percent, if that.
The tidal wave of machine learning runs through
a number of different scientific fields. Will
deep learning techniques establish supremacy
in these areas? Hard to say yet, but what
we know for sure is that great strides are
made literally every week. There are so many
works out there, sometimes I don't even know
where to start. Good times indeed!
Before we go, some delightful news for you
Fellow Scholars! The Scholarly Two Minute
Papers store is now open! There are two different
kinds of men's T-shirts available, and a nice
sleek design version that we made for the
Fellow Scholar ladies out there! We also have
The Scholarly Mug to get your day started
in the most scientific way possible.
We have tested the quality of these products
and were really happy with what we got. If
you ordered anything, please provide us feedback
on how you liked the quality of the delivery
and the products themselves. If you can send
us an image of yourself wearing or using any
of these, we'd love to have a look. Just leave
them in the comments section or tweet at us!
If you don't like what you got, within 30
days, you can exchange it or get your product
cost refunded.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!